October 26th is Judgment Day for
Europe's banks the first stress tests of
the financial system in three years will
reveal once and for all which lenders
are equipped to survive an economic
shock if it works credit should start
flowing again and Europe will be jolted
out of its slump the last round of tests
in the aftermath of the sovereign debt
crisis wasn't stressful enough and the
results were incredible
this time 130 banks are under the
microscope in a two-part process run by
the European Central Bank and the
European Banking Authority the first is
a review of asset quality that'll
determine which banks have too many bad
loans the second is the actual stress
test which simulates crisis conditions
to gauge the resilience of bank balance
sheets ideally some banks will fail
otherwise the whole exercise won't
inspire confidence some of the most
vulnerable lenders are in Greece Austria
Italy and Portugal the bigger question
is how financial giants like Deutsche
Bank Barclays and BNP Paribas do any
institution falling short we'll have two
weeks to submit a capital plan and just
six to nine months to complete it